[Music]  Shawn Mendes showing his support for  Camilla Kibeho  the two collaborated on his single I  know what you did last summer her first  solo endeavor before officially calling  it quits from fifth harmony I knew she  was gonna do that she's gonna do so much  more - this is just the beginning for  her are you working on you've been  teasing some announcements yeah well you  know we're just working on two rare  announcements some new music that I can  tell you about working on it so I'm not  sure what I want to do exactly yeah well  tell me that's what's inspiring you  right now just being back I mean the  years kind of starting right now for me  so I'm happy to be back and working and  tell me about the tour tour is gonna be  insane it's a massive massive set and  first time playing arenas and the whole  new album we're going to be playing in  beautiful beautiful production it's  gonna be good  you